Republicans ready to R subpoenas down on
Hunter Biden new house Speaker Mike
Johnson signaling that a new phase in
the impeachment inquiry into President
Biden could be starting we are going to
follow the law and follow the
Constitution and I think we you and I
have a suspicion of where that may lead
but we're going to let the evidence
speak for itself and I I look forward to
uh rolling that out over the coming days
and weeks and letting the American
people see exactly why we're taking the
next steps and where it's headed are you
expecting to subpoena Hunter Biden I'm
looking at that I you know I think that
U desperate times call for desperate
measures and that perhaps is is overdue
we've not made a full decision yet the
house has been busy gathering evidence
but the media is trying to dismiss
it Politico doesn't think it's a big
deal that Joe Biden received $200,000
check from his brother James Biden which
the White House says it was just some
money Joe loaned him when his brother
needed
it um they keep saying Jesse No Smoking
Gun this is the time in which you un
furl the Arsenal of smoking guns you
have 2 minutes and 18 seconds I don't
need it Jessica and her ilk for years
have said well you don't have money
going directly into Joe Biden's bank
account all right so now we have a check
for
$200,000 from one company through the
brother to Joe's bank account okay you
still say okay well that's not from
overseas that was a loan okay okay okay
what
happens if the next check mhm originates
somewhere really bad Jessica and I mean
really bad and it goes through hunter or
it goes through James and it goes
directly into Joe Biden's checking
account is that your Smoking
Gun is that your Smoking Gun Jessica
because you said that was a Smoking Gun
if money went from overseas directly
into Joe Biden's bank account if a check
comes out at some
point from that Avenue
is that a Smoking Gun okay um so two
things yes or no yes or no no it's not
it's not wait whoa whoa Jessica for a
year you said oh woman money never hit
his bank account what if I have a check
that hits his bank account that comes
from overseas okay so is that not a
Smoking Gun okay is he in elected office
and did he do something about it so that
check that 2018 check when he was not
doing anything except hanging around and
there was an exp for it so if you get a
check and then you can connect that to
an action that he took oh no now it's an
action that he took that has always now
it's just an action that he took because
before you said none of the money from
overseas went into his checking account
so now it's an action you are yelling
and there is no reason for it there's
reason I was promised a Smoking Gun and
if I deliver a Smoking Gun you have to
admit that gun is smoking um excuse me
can I just say something to all the guns
out there don't smoke
really bad for you thank you can I say
something else yeah you can finish your
yes okay um I appreciated that Jesse I
always learned something from you um out
so the new speaker Mike Johnson um
hardly uh a resounding we got it when he
says desperate times call for desperate
measures and the reason that he said
that is because James comr last week is
with a gaggle of Hill reporters and said
I don't know what that I want to hold
any more hearings to be honest now if
you had it if there any smoking guns
around you'd probably have more
hearings where the car come from where
did the car come from what they bried
him with oh my God and I have a diamond
stuck in my hair and whatever else say I
would encourage everyone to read Jamie
Rasin has a
new fake member of Congress okay and it
lists the top 10 comr faleh hes
including the BS testimony that was
build is going to be some Smoking Gun
again and it was a Chinese foreign
National who's dead Devon Archer's
testimony go look at that that Biden
obstructed the investigation no guns
have been smoked yet I am sorry ex me
you want to see two smoking
guns that was my way of getting out of
it uh judge the Dems love to say Trump
is not above the law well neither is the
Biden Syndicate family oh yes they are
Joe Biden is president of course they're
Above the Law I mean give me a break of
course they're going to they're going to
subina but you know what's so special
about the loan check that went from
James to Joe re payment of a loan proof
to me it was a loan I want to see the
loan document I want to know what the
interest was I want to know the payment
schedule I want to know what would
happen What would if there were a
penalty is there a prepayment penalty I
mean 2,000 one Fell Swoop hey that just
reads repayment of a loan that doesn't
mean anything all right now now let's
just be really clear about this he's
never going to be able to prove it was a
loone because James got it from a
hospital James Biden where there was all
kinds of corruption and fraud and there
were lawsuits for that and James had to
pay money back but let's just say that
the Democrats can go against Donald
Trump for four years on Russia okay but
God forbid the Republicans try to
unearth the $24 million that's gone into
the Biden family account
forget about this you know the uh uh uh
the the uh which reports are the SARS
reports forget about the emails the text
messages the photographs yeah I know I
have to be quick but at the same time
there are millions of dollars
$200,000 with no explanation Hunter says
half of his income goes to his father
Hunter pays for his father's personal
expenses email aliases that Joe Biden
uses to talk to Hunter photo of Joe
Biden with Hunter business partners when
when Joe says he knows nothing about his
son's businesses the president of the
United States has been lying to us and
he's been protecting his son that's
enough for an investigation Dana I'll
just say that um so much for the most
transparent Administration in history
because they're so like trying to hide
all of this and the if you take for the
Republicans advantages right now they
have it on inflation border War crime
you take all of those issues you focus
on those and then you might additionally
have a de evidence of a Smoking Gun the
Republicans would be in pretty good
shape for November 2024 there you go all
right coming up tributes pouring in
following the death of friend star
Matthew Perry hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else